thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
the first thousand people to click the
link in the description
can get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
[Laughter]
hi hello it's me again
debokey writer and occasional host for a
journey to the microcosmos
and i'm here to confess something kind
of
shameful to you all the first time i saw
a picture of a tardigrade
i didn't think it was real
i just remember looking at this animal
that looked like a cross between a dog
and
the michelin man and it was even more
strange to conceive of how tiny it is
and that
out there in the world are just bits of
moss with animals like this one
gliding through them now that i've spent
some more time in the micro cosmos
tardigrades seem almost normal almost
i mean they are animals and at the end
of the day
you don't have to be tiny to be a weird
looking animal
but animals have the advantage of many
many
cells to build their different bodies
on the other hand unicellular organisms
like bacteria
and protists have less to work with and
yet
they manage to take on so many strange
and unusual forms
just think about it if you were asked to
draw a cell
what would you draw maybe your
imagination is better than mine but
i would probably sketch a vaguely round
thing
maybe add some extra hairs on the
outside if i'm feeling creative
nature has a lot more clever ideas
though
trumpets and spirals and floral
arrangements
all made out of single cells of course
these shapes aren't just for fun an
organism's shape is connected to the
world it lives in
though sometimes the factors shaping
them are beyond our understanding
it can be difficult at times to narrow
down
why a microbe takes on a particular
shape
when the reality of the micro cosmos
is that in any environment you can find
a whole plethora of shapes that might
seem to have
nothing in common it's also easy
to look at the existence of a living
thing and assume that every detail of
its being
has been optimized through eons of
mutations
and selection for a specific purpose
and there is an extent to which that's
true the world places
all sorts of demands on life the need
for food
for reproduction for warmth for light
for dark for movement
and we respond in kind by prioritizing
and balancing those needs
and shape is one way we do that
but it's one thing to come up with
stories for why something might be
advantageous it's a much more involved
process to prove it
take spirochetes for example which are
distinctive
thanks to their helical shape they're
also
not great for us they're infectious
able to dig into us and invade our
bodies
and it's been hypothesized that part of
how they do this
is through that corkscrew shape which
might help them move through
thick viscous solutions you know like
our
insides but proving this hypothesis
took a lot of work scientists spent
decades studying spirochetes and viscous
solutions and mouse stomachs
as well as comparing them to other
bacteria all just to show that this
shape gives them a physical advantage in
colonizing bodies
and even then there are still so many
aspects of the helical life
and the advantages it provides them that
are still conjecture
[Music]
and that's true for bacteria in general
which can take on
so many shapes spheres rods filaments
stalks
but whatever the shape the building
material is the same
peptidoglycan a combination of amino
acid
and sugar that links together to form a
strong lattice
that holds the bacteria in all its
contents within
the structure of the bacteria cell wall
can vary
along with its shape one group of
bacteria
called gram-negative bacteria generally
have thinner walls and an additional
outer membrane
gram-positive bacteria in contrast
generally have a thicker
multi-layered wall but like many
categorizations in biology this
dichotomy is just
a tad bit too simple
one of the largest groups of bacteria
are cyanobacteria
and their diversity is even more
astounding
there are cyanobacteria like the
merismopedia for example
that form flat colonies held together by
a mucilaginous matrix like this their
round shape
neatly arranged like candy dots
and then you have other cyanobacteria
like these long filamentous forms that
glide along
surfaces cyanobacteria are generally
categorized as gram-negative bacteria
because their cells have that extra
outer membrane we talked about
but cyanobacteria also have a thick
peptidoglycan layer
which makes them sort of like
gram-positive bacteria too
and that strange combination of traits
underlies the spectacular diversity of
cyanobacteria
single-celled eukaryotes or protists
have a wide range of exteriors too
but much of our understanding of their
shape comes from their cytoskeleton
a network of filaments and microtubules
that coordinates many essential
functions in the cell
and when it comes to shape it might seem
unusual to focus
on the amoeba which is so often known
for its shapelessness
especially as they move it's hard not to
look at a blob
and think of it as accidental but the
forming of pseudopodia
or false feet to help the amoeba move
requires a complex architecture of
microtubules
to support this shifting shape and of
course
there are many protists that take on
very different shapes
whether that's for defense or for food
or for some other reason
there are pediatrics that form these
spiky colonies that protect them from
algae eaters
and then there are opercularia which
look like little flowers
attached to branches and husilia you can
see at work
gathering food as it floats on by
it'd be difficult to describe all the
shapes that protists take
on because there are just so many
even it feels like when compared to
bacteria
some scientists have argued that
bacterial diversity is more
internal than external a function of
metabolic reactions we can't see
but protists have adapted more with
their shape
leaving us with a world where the
diversity itself is multifaceted
we've spent this episode talking about
the diversity of shapes in the
microcosmos
in part because that's what we can show
you but we've seen
over and over again the way that shapes
have misled scientists when it comes to
classifying organisms
or the way that the shape of something
can actually lead to more questions
that can only be answered by studying
the inside of the cell
but that's the joy of shape it's an
entry point into the micro cosmos
a way for us to wonder about organism
and environment alike
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
we'd like to also say thank you again to
skillshare for supporting this video
on skillshare you can put your new
knowledge of shapes to good use with
classes like
vector illustration design a playful
character using geometric shapes
which is taught by illustrator jonathan
ball from concept and sketch to creating
vectors and shading
you'll learn how to start with geometric
shapes and ultimately end up with
something from another dimension
or maybe even the micro cosmos if you
decide to create your own
illustrated microbe skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore
real world projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth it's curated specifically
for learning
meaning there are no ads to distract you
and they're always launching new premium
classes
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and an annual subscription to skillshare
is less than ten dollars a month
if you're one of the first 1000 people
to click the link in the description
you can get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
the names on the screen right now those
are our patreon patrons
and without them this show would not get
to exist
so thank you to each and every one of
you who support this channel
we'd like to let you know that we'll be
taking next week off from uploading
but we'll have a brand new video for you
on may 31st
and if you'd like to see some very good
microbes in the meantime
be sure to follow our master of
microscopes james weiss
at jammin germs on instagram and you can
also pre-order james's book
the hidden beauty of the microscopic
world wherever books are sold
and if you'd like to see more from us
make sure to click that subscribe
[Music]
button
you